you know what's interesting daredevil is
set in a very dark violent New York you
know in and and I'm wondering if that's
being in that show is making you because
you live in New York City is it making
you a little more paranoid being around
New York you know what I mean is it
because you're on that set all day long
and it's it's a very murky violent
vision of New York City yeah well New
York has that aspect to it and that's a
real thing and I grew up as a New Yorker
so I you know I grew up being prepared
for that walking down the street with
keys in my hand and you know it's that
kind of thing and now it's you know
people think it's so safe in New York
that they're walking around with ear
buds at four o'clock in the morning and
I kind of feel like hitting them yeah I
literally walk down the streets of New
York now and it's so nice the people are
like it's New York it's Korea and I'm
like target target target target
please don't empty out your bag cuz
you're drunk on the corner and you're
trying to find your keys let me put you
in a cab and send you on your way and
rob you a little bit just because then I
just to show
I like that when you say I love that you
want to rob people a little bit $800 I'm
taking 200 if I'm rolling up behind you
because you can't hear me because you
got your buzz in your head you kind of
but it does it does feel like it does
feel like New York City has been so
safer there's been that perception for
so long that people do for the years
that I lived there I would see people
just being way too chill sometimes in
any areas we'd be like come on just have
a little bit of common sense yeah no
this is great actually to be coming back
now and be China talking about that
gritty New York and the Hell's Kitchen
sort of version of it the version that
had my mom you know teach me how to use
pepper spray but it was so sad we were
like in this tiny little studio
apartment
my mom was 26 I was 10 my brother was 5
and she was like well let's to be clean
let's go in the bathroom so when we go
into this even smaller space and she
like so this is how you use pepper spray
I'm like you don't know what you're
doing all but now we're all going to go
in this closet and test this grenade I
found
you